make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and a
couple things one this room is or this
audio is probably very echoey because of
the fact that i am currently in an empty
room because all of our stuff is in a
moving truck and we are heading back to
colorado and we're leaving tomorrow
morning so i have
four hours to crank out four videos
about the multiverse about like the
multiversal hierarchy
and so that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna run over the multiversal hierarchy
or at least the new multiversal
hierarchy as i see it right now this is
not by any means an absolute
right everybody kind of has their own
interpretation of this but given the
years that i've been reading comics
given what i've been reading so far
this is how i interpret i would say
probably the 20 most powerful beings
in all of marvel comics so starting at
the bottom right number 20 all the way
to number 15 right starting at the very
bottom here we have the house of m
scarlet witch now here's the thing
right i would chalk up the house of m
scarlet witch under normal circumstances
as being somebody whose power exceeded
the cosmic entities right so like
eternity
infinity all those various beings who
are out there and then capping off on a
universal scale
under normal circumstances i would say
that i would be like that's it for the
scholar witch right she's a universal
level threat
except for one story that existed out
there and that was written by peter
david in 2008 and his x factor vol 3
issue number 25. and the reason why this
matters is because this took place
during masai
complex and what it basically
established is that the
scarlet witch when she had said no more
mutants at the end of house of m
it wasn't just the main marvel universe
that was affected it affected the entire
multiverse and in fact
entire timelines had lost their mutant
populations it's the reason why it's
believed in the old man logan's
storyline that no more mutants were
being born after a period of time
because for whatever reason
uh that i guess that timeline's a little
bit different in terms of how time
passes i don't really know but the long
and short of it is that when the scarlet
witch said no more mutants is believed
to have affected that timeline we don't
know for certain it's never been
confirmed but the fact that scarlet
witch's power was on such a scale that
she was able to effectively mix
98 of the beaten population from getting
powers and you know in the aftermath or
the conclusion of house of m
is pretty huge so while she's not really
able to alter reality on a multiversal
scale or able to present herself as a
threat to like some of the most powerful
heavy hitters that exist out there in
the multiverse she can
affect the multiverse and that's pretty
huge right that's pretty massive so
that's why i got her all the way at the
bottom
of the list now after scarlet witch
we've got the first
firmament right the first universe and
here's the reason why i put this here
those of you guys who don't really know
the first universe is basically where
the multiverse hails from right so the
way this plays out this this took place
in al ewing's ultimates
is part of all new all different marvel
and the way that it's explained here is
that when the one above all originally
created
everything the only thing it did was
create the first universe and that was
it right and it just kind of gave the
universe sentience and then just
wanted to see what happened the first
universe in turn was driven by
loneliness
and it created the the beings that we
know as aspirants right now these
aspirants ended up splitting into two
factions
those who were loyal to the first
universe meaning they created planets
and stars and life and all that kind of
stuff but did so
only after presenting it to the first
universe and asking for its approval
uh they stayed aspirants those
individuals who rebelled who looked at
the the first universe and said no
you know the you know all of reality
needs to learn to understand growth
and change in mortality uh they became
celestials and what it did is it led to
a holy war between the two groups that
you had the celestials and the aspirants
that went to war with each other and
basically shattered the first
universe now the first universe ended up
surviving its consciousness continue to
exist and when you went to all new all
different marvel the first universe was
powerful enough
to chain the entirety of the multiverse
right it was called multiversal eternity
the multiverse was in a weakened state
so it wasn't really the full totality of
its power but any being out there that's
capable of essentially ensnaring and
shutting down and capturing the the
multiverse itself
that's a powerful person right that's
huge again we're not really seeing like
massive amounts of reality warping we're
not seeing it just completely shut down
and destroy the multiverse wiping it out
of existence and and removing it from
all creation
but the fact that it's able to overpower
the living embodiment of the multiverse
puts i think on on the top 20 most
powerful beings in the history of marvel
comics so from there we go into my next
selection here
and this next selection i think is going
to be a little controversial right it's
going to be a little controversial i'm
putting the white phoenix of the crown
and the reason why i'm putting the white
phoenix of the crown here
is the white phoenix is powerful but we
haven't seen the full totality of the
white phoenix's power so for those of
you guys who don't know how this works
you have of course individuals out there
who are capable of being a host for the
phoenix force i'm sure you guys have
heard of that and the phoenix force
basically represents the sum total of
all life that has ever currently does
and will ever exist
across the multiverse but there are some
individuals out there that are deemed to
be
essentially perfect hosts for the
phoenix force right they just line up
exceptionally well the most popular
version of that
is jean grey and jean grey becoming the
white phoenix of the crown the way it
was explained in the story here comes
tomorrow by grant morrison was pretty
ambiguous right it was just the white
phoenix fix what's broken right and
that's it right it just kind of fixes
the universe but the long and short of
the power of the white phoenix of the
crown is that it has the ability to burn
universes away right to wipe out what's
broken so though the white phoenix of
the crown can destroy
entire universes but the reason why i
have the white phoenix of the crown
listed so low here
is because we haven't really seen her do
a lot we don't really know the full
totality of her power we know that hosts
of the phoenix force can be killed
by a sufficient amount of power an
example being god king doom killing
cyclops when he had the phoenix force so
like we know that that can happen
even if a person has 100 percent like
the full use of the phoenix
it does not necessarily mean they're the
white phoenix and so if an individual
who is the white phoenix of the crown
effectively possesses the 100 totality
of the phoenix forces powers technically
their powers are limitless but just
because a person has limitless powers or
a being has limitless powers does not
necessarily mean they're the most
powerful being in existence because when
you're talking about
cosmic entities and various things like
that sure their power is
limitless but marvel kind of chalks that
up and says there's somebody whose power
is more limitless i don't quite know how
you square that circle but
whatever it is how it is they use their
powers and what another person is
experienced enough to know how to use
the full totality of their powers
also plays a role as well but that's why
i have the white phoenix of the crown
basically listed as like number 17
essentially on our list but then we go
into my next selection here
and this is going to be one that i think
is going to be really intriguing but
could also be one
where people are just like what okay my
next selection here
is the ultimate ultimates right so where
you had the ultimate avengers right the
multiversal avengers basically so you
had uh adam beshear and you had black
panther and you had uh monica rambo
and captain marvel and america chavez
where you had a lot of like these really
powerful characters out there
the ultimate ultimates were basically a
coming together of all the other
universes
that predate the current universe right
so at the time the story was written you
had what was called the eighth cosmos or
the eighth
universe and then you have all the other
iterations that came before right now
technically it looks like it was more of
the multiverse than anything else the
eighth iteration of the multiverse as
opposed to the eighth iteration of the
universe but what you're essentially
talking about is the ultimate ultimate
being a collection
or a team of individuals who are
essentially the previous versions of the
multiverse
given physical form right so imagine if
captain america represented a whole
multiverse unto himself and that's
basically what this is right this team
is powerful um the reason why i have
this team listed here
is because of the fact that when the
first firmament was able to capture the
multiversal eternity that it basically
took a combination
of really all the all the ultimate
ultimates in order to capture or in
order to defeat the first firmament
that's the level of power that we're
talking about here
these guys are well beyond the abilities
of beings like galactus and stuff like
that these guys are huge right to give
you guys perspective
uh each one of these multiverses
contains a
seemingly infinite number of universes
and within each one of those universes
you have a galactus and you have a
dormammu
and you have a doctor strange and you
have a scarlet witch
right that's in each one of these
universes and each one of these
infinitely expanding multiverses which
is represented by
a singular member of the ultimate
ultimates right it's it's nuts how
powerful these guys are but here's a
funny thing
they're still at the bottom of the list
which really begs the question how
powerful
are we going to get here in terms of the
abilities that people have that's what's
so bonkers about this right so following
that the the last option the last
selection that i have here
is the multiversal eternity and i think
a lot of you guys were
picking up on that you know the the
multiversal eternity as he exists now
the reason why i selected this guy
being more powerful than seemingly the
others is because the way it's kind of
explained in al ewing's ultimates is
that the current version of the
multiversal eternity really is the most
powerful version of eternity that's
existed throughout the various
cosmoses who have existed to give you
guys a little bit of understanding here
in marvel comics within the main marvel
universe just this one singular universe
you do have a cosmic entity called
eternity and eternity is an answer to
the question what if the universe could
get up and walk around
and talk to people and that's how
eternity works technically speaking he's
what's called an
abstract and each one of the cosmic
entities have to travel to what's called
the realm of anthropomorpho
and receive what's what's referred to as
an embody essentially a physical form
that they kind of step into they channel
their essence into and then that's when
you see them appear
across the universe uh but while each
one of the universes inside of a
multiverse has its own eternity
you also have multiversal eternity and
he's an answer to the question what if
the multiverse could get up and walk
around and talk to people and so the way
it's explained again in al ewing's
ultimates is
the eighth iteration of the multiversal
eternity is the most powerful
of all the other iterations that have
existed and when you look at the idea of
the ultimate ultimates and you look at
the first firmament you look at the
conflict as it was
that the multiversal eternity in the the
eighth version as it exists now
was technically captured by the first
firmament it could not actually be
destroyed or defeated and the reality is
that it was still in a weakened state
which really kind of begs the question
what would it look like in a powerful
state
and we do have an answer to that right
it is exceedingly powerful it is huge
but the funny thing about this is these
are the bottom
five right these are the bottom five
what do the rest of the 15
look like you know it's it's going to
get kind of nuts i'm not even going to
lie to you it's going to get kind of
silly
in terms of some of the power that we
have with regards to the most powerful
beings to exist
across the multiverse and marvel comics
so with that being said guys we're going
to bring this video to an
end if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
you